enfin les soleils et partout la Terre du
Ciel c'est au milieu de vie où l'on
navigue entre les cris et la recherche
d'apaisement
ou deux semaines c'est la visite de
l'enseignant en musique
au quotidien la routine est rythmée par
l'explosion de frustration des gestes de
réconfort et des efforts pour mieux
communiquer on a beaucoup d'usagers qui
sont non verbaux font qu'on est
difficulté des difficultés de
communication si les besoins sont pas
répondu ou qui sont pas compris ou que
eux arrivent pas à se faire comprendre
ou à exprimer quelque chose ça peut
créer des frustrations des
désorganisations agressives huit jeunes
de 10 à 17 ans habitent dans cette unité
ouverte l'été dernier ils vivent avec
une déficience intellectuelle de
l'autisme et surtout un trouble grave du
comportement
après on y va
on va s'asseoir tu dois être calme
pour prévenir les crises on leur apprend
à exprimer leurs besoins avec des
pictogrammes je veux écouter la musique
quand il a besoin de quelque chose il
vient et prendre classeur il me donne le
pictogramme puis on regarde avec son sa
programmation de la journée à quel
moment on va pouvoir répondre à cette
demande-là s'il faut tout le temps avoir
en tête qu'il peut y avoir des
situations qui peuvent se produire qui
peut y avoir un risque soit d'agression
des fois c'est des usagers qui vont
aussi faire des autos en question donc
ils vont faire de l'automutilation
cette unité est souvent le dernier
recours de famille ou de ressources
d'hébergement dépassé par le
comportement d'un jeune ça change la
dynamique les interventions sont plus
faciles aussi qu'on est dans un dans un
milieu qui est adapté à notre réalité là
on y trouve huit chambres individuelles
une salle à manger deux salles communes
un poste d'observation et une salle
d'apaisement
puis la sécurité aussi qui peut être
faite donc on pense entre autres au
matériaux qui sont qui ont été utilisés
pour construire l'unité il y a eu des
grandes réflexions pour vraiment trouver
c'est quoi la bonne formule pour pouvoir
acquérir et encadrer ces jeunes là donc
on parle de matériaux en allant jusqu'à
la couleur qui est utilisée pour un
milieu très épuré le mobilier aussi on y
trouve aussi beaucoup de personnes
outre une équipe de spécialistes
ergothérapeute orthophoniste
psycho-éducateur il y a pour chaque
jeune une éducatrice pivot et un
va se rapprocher l'éducateur lui va
faire son travail il dispose d'outils
cet immense ballon permet chaque jour
d'éviter des contacts physiques et une
escalade menant à la crise on peut
enlever le ballon merci beaucoup le
séjour ici transitoire après cet
encadrement intensif on souhaite que la
majorité puisse apprendre à gérer leur
comportement
une enseignante spécialisée du centre de
services scolaire de Montréal est
présente tous les jours c'est juste deux
minutes après
le rythme évidemment mais ça a commencé
où je travaillais sous une table avec
une jeune donc
ça c'est quand on a des petits progrès
comme ça quand même c'est je pense que
c'est nos petits cadeaux ce qu'on espère
c'est vraiment améliorer leur donner les
outils pour arriver à mieux communiquer
pour ensuite qui réintègre une école
spécialisée et à plus long terme qui est
réintègre la société
pour assurer la stabilité des jeunes il
faut aussi une stabilité dans l'équipe
qui s'occupe d'eux un défi quand la main
devrait rare et puis l'unité des caries
soutient aussi les parents on offre
aussi un coaching aux parents pour leur
montrer les outils qui fonctionnent bien
quels sont les interventions à
préconiser avec leur enfant en ayant une
unité comme ça qui est temporaire ils
viennent ils reçoivent le service
intensif qui ensuite sont redirigés soit
chez maman papa ou dans un autre type
d'hébergement
[Musique]
le sieste du centre sud de l'île de
Montréal veut doubler la capacité à 16
chambres pour accueillir des plus jeunes
on croit que cette unité spéciale
correspondra aux nouvelles orientations
que le ministre Lionel karma voit
annoncer au printemps prochain les
étoiles filantes
Montréal